Carter and I have been blessed with the
Rival our baby boy no one knew literally
until he was like over a week old Paris
Hilton didn't just keep her bombshell
baby news a secret from the world she
kept it from those closest to her too
not even my mom my sister my best
friends you'd think I'd know the air is
shocked fans last month announcing she
was a first-time mama she and her hubby
Carter Reem didn't share that they were
expecting before welcoming their bundle
of joy a baby boy named Phoenix via
surrogate he is such a precious angel
and we are just over the moon and so in
love with him we're just so excited to
start our family and
can't wait for you to see him but
but we've just been keeping everything
really private
so private that Paris didn't tell her
mom Kathy or sister Nikki their family
was expanding no one knew literally
until he was like over a week old I just
feel that my life has been so public and
I've never really had
anything just be mine I feel like just
my life in so many ways has been invaded
and yeah it's just been it's been a lot
and Carter's always been a very private
person as well we're just so excited to
throw our life together in the future
last year we learned why Paris might not
always want to clue her mom into top
secret news because in November Paris
had to shut down Kathy's claims that she
was struggling to concede I don't know
where she came up with that I was like
Mom I've never even talked about that
with you
and you know you just like say things
you're not even thinking to just get
people to stop asking me I said and I I
just said oh I know and I said you know
it is hard I think going and taking oh
yeah that that hurts and she'll complain
she's bloated and you know the first
time probably getting myself in more
trouble and also you were put on the
spot and you answered the question in
the moment so I thought well this will
stop them asking and then they made a
whole new oh my God yes miscommunication
aside things now seem
Kathy's now a grandma of six and
couldn't be more excited about Paris
adding to their next Generation saying
that she and her husband Rick are so
overwhelmed and filled with joy over
their newest grandson quote we are so
thrilled for Paris and Carter and look
forward to all the happy memories we
will make as a family my life is so
complete now I've always wanted to be a
mom and I'm just so happy that I found
the perfect partner
Carter he is just
such an angel and such an incredible
father I just love this baby so much
just when he's laying on my chest and
looking up into my eyes
my heart just melts I am
so in love and he is so precious
[Music]
thank you